foreign
[Music]
Dan LM
okay here we go
we're doing ten plus five so a bit of a
compromise between 15 plus 10 and 10
plus zero okay so we're facing the NIMS
of each opening which is Knight C6
and Knight C6 in most cases has fairly
little what is called in chess
independent value you'll hear this
phrase in opening books and basically
that means if an opening has little
independent value then it generally
transposes into another opening now if
white plays D4 then you get an
independent opening but it's much easier
and more convenient to play Knight F3
here because most of the time black
plays E5 and then you don't have to
learn a separate opening we can just
play our normal stuff
okay I think I'm in the mood for another
Belgrade Gambit I'm in the mood for
another Belgrade Gambit let's go for it
and see how it holds up at a relatively
high level let's go Knight C3
now so far we've played the four night
scotch and we've played the Vienna of
course you cannot play the Vienna if you
play two Knight F3 black plays E5 so
that is the one downside is the Vienna
has been eliminated let's see how the
Belgrade Gambit fares at this level
let's go D4 probably black is going to
take now we have also faced the move
Bishop D4 which is kind of a bishop B4
which is kind of an old move which is an
old move and I will not remember how to
play against it I remember Bishop before
we played D5 which is apparently wrong
so if he plays Bishop before we will
try to recollect the theory I think
Bishop before Knight takes C5 was the
line
okay 84 and of course the Belgrade
Gambit which is Knight D5 which we've
already played once so I'll insert the
link if you're watching on YouTube I'll
put the link to our previous Belgrade
Gambit game in that game yeah we faced
we faced I think the immediate D6 I'll
check I'll check what we faced in the
previous Belgium now night before
essentially tells me that black knows
what he's doing black knows what they're
doing if he plays Knight before because
this is a move which is commonly
recommended I guess in books and the
engine likes this move but when I was
analyzing the Belgrade I found that
white has a very interesting weapon
which doesn't look like anything special
but I think it rejuvenates the line so
against night before you take the Knight
on F6 and first of all against Queen
takes F6 God forbid do not take on D4
obviously because there's a simple
tactic Queen takes D4 Queen takes D4 and
Knight C takes C2 picks up the piece so
we need to chase the Knight away with A3
and now you play okay the Knight has to
drop back to C6 it's the only reasonable
square and in this position there is
this like I I hesitate to call it a
computer move because it is just a
developing move but there are some
subtleties behind this move that must be
understood for this move to be
appreciated and I've played this in in
uh casual Blitz and stuff so if you
watch my stream often you you this might
be familiar to you if you're looking at
this for the first time with white first
of all it may seem like there's no good
way to reclaim the pawn and it is true
you're basically playing this Gambit
style
um you will only reclaim the pawn if
black plays the move D6 so our goal is
to meet D6 with the move Bishop to B5
but for the time being we still need to
develop our Bishop so we play this with
Bishop D3 which is kind of a flexible
move
and what this move signals to you is
that we are not trying to actively win
the spawn back unless black black plays
D6 then we play Bishop B5 which is a
very convenient move and the reason it's
a very convenient move is because it
pins the Knight and now we are ready to
recapture this Pawn hopefully with a
small Advantage now black has a computer
line here that gives black a good
position but I have encountered maybe
one GM who's played this and he is
playing all of the top computer moves
here Queen takes D4
and here the computer line is Bishop E7
in all of my experience playing online
maybe like two or three people have
played like this it's very very rare to
know this line and it's not like black
is better in the sense that oh you know
um white has nothing to play for and you
see he plays Queen takes D4 and we get
into an end game and this end game I
think is very pleasant for white and I
really like that we get an end game
because we haven't had that many end
games like longer end games in the
speedrun so I really can try to dig deep
and and try to explain how I try to
outplay good players in the end game not
that I'm particularly good at it but
I'll do my best
so of course the end game should be
equal here but maybe white has a smidge
I think we are just a tiny bit better
why are we a tiny bit better well
there's two reasons the first is we have
slightly better control of the center
but the main reason is that after we
capture on C6 and we have to decide what
we're capturing with we will somewhat
damage Black's Queen Side Pawn structure
we can play Bishop takes C6 or we can
play Knight takes C6 we don't have to
take on C6 we can play this move Bishop
E3 just keeping the status quo which is
also a reasonable move but I don't like
it
um I think we should take the
opportunity to damage black spawn
structure and I think we should do it
with the Knight
this may be less appealing to you
because BC now comes with the tempo but
I don't want to just hand over the
bishop here just like that I don't want
to hand over the bishop pair and I don't
want to hand over uncontested control of
the light squares
so for example if we had taken with the
bishop after BC black would be able to
play C5 and chase this Knight out of the
center and then maybe even F5 expanding
on the king side so I like the concept
of leaving the Bishops on the board
and here we have another choice and all
of these decisions that we're about to
make are not essential they are not
essential in the sense that if you make
the wrong move here you're screwed I
absolutely don't think that I think that
you just need to follow your intuition
and not spend too long on these calls
first let's play Bishop D3 I liked the
look of Bishop A6 but after Bishop A6
Rook B8 it felt to me that this bishop
was not doing enough and it was also not
supporting the E4 Pawn which is one of
the main sort of elements of our
position so it makes sense for this Pawn
to be well protected now this bishop may
look bad to you but okay remember that a
piece can play a defensive role and that
doesn't mean it's a bad piece so don't
be dismissive about the fact that the
Bishop's not controlling squares
therefore it's a bad Bishop not really
and Bishop C4 I didn't like because of
Bishop E6 and we want to avoid trades if
possible now let's continue our
development so let's consider where we
put this bishop I like the look of
Bishop E3 in order to put some pressure
on the A7 Pawn
let's go Bishop E3 we are not committing
to the placement of our King just yet
which is a deliberate by Design because
I don't know what black is going to do
so depending on how black is going to
position their pieces I'm going to
decide whether we're going kingside or
queen side or staying in the center
which is also possible because it's the
end game but I don't think so I think my
fault they're a little bit too many
pieces here for us to stay in the center
I would be a little bit worried if we
stayed in the center that black would
put a rook on E8 and we would start
pressing us so okay so this is a good
case in point Bishop F6 so we have a
move here that simultaneously develops
our King and protects this B2 pawn and I
think it's worth taking this opportunity
Castle queenside
this also puts the Rook on a nice square
right D1 Square
and what does The Rook on D1 doing well
it's x-raying the bishop and you have to
realize already at this stage I'll say
that this end game cannot be won quickly
black is way too solid for you to expect
that we're gonna develop a winning
advantage in five moves we're probably
not even gonna develop winning advantage
in 10 moves maybe at all you have to
play very gradually you have to make
small improving moves and you have to be
okay with settling in for a long end
game so first thing is like a mentality
issue Rook B8 okay
there is a funny trick where we can play
Bishop A7 but the problem is black as
Bishop takes B2 check if Rook takes B2
we would have this move E5 there but
it's a moot point okay so we can go B3
can go C3
B3 actually doesn't look as bad I don't
think it's as bad as it looks you know
what the what the plus side of B3 is so
after we play B3 black is likely to play
A5 I think to develop defend the pawn
and then we can build this uh this Pawn
chain with A4 and the benefit of the
move A4 is that it fixes Black's Pawn on
a dark square and one of the things that
we want to do in this end game is create
long-term weaknesses the more long-term
weaknesses we create the the better you
know our long-term chances become
um we can also play C3 which also has
the major benefit of blunting this
bishop and and reducing the influence of
Black's Bishop so both B3 and C3 makes
sense I don't like B4 as much I feel
like that's a little bit too committal I
although you know B4 also a case could
be made for that move
B3 Bishop C3 is a little bit scary yeah
that's what worries me
okay
hmm
I don't know what to play here let me
think
B3 Bishop C3 is annoying but we have
ways to deal with it we can play Bishop
E2 and with D3 for example very very
hard decision very hard decision the
problem also with C3 is that we create a
long time yeah let's go B3 let's go B3
let's go B3 by the way this is not my
intuition I'm going against my intuition
my intuition is to play C3
like in a bullet game I play C3 for sure
but I feel like when I approach this
more deeply I want to avoid creating
long-term weaknesses of our own and one
of the deciding factors for me against
C3 okay we go A4 and we fix the pawn is
that when we play C3 the B2 Pawn becomes
a long-term weakness and black has this
plan that involves doubling Rooks on the
B file and applying pressure on it which
I don't really want to allow here are
pawns on the queen side are very healthy
now we should keep in mind that there's
a very typical plan in such structures
that should be we should be very
Vigilant about trying to either prevent
or take this thing out of in some
situations does anybody know how this
Pawn structure can be dealt with by
black in in some situations yeah so
there's this typical plan which involves
trying to break apart uh the pawn chain
right and you're probably familiar with
the general concept of breaking apart a
pawn chain here black could try to
advance the pawn to C4 not right now but
in general and if we have to play B take
C4 then we get our own weakness on A4
and the B file opens up okay Bishop C3
play all right so here I really like the
concept of Bishop C4 and Rook D3
let's do it Bishop C4 and Rook D3 trying
to smoke the bishop out of C3 now you
might say well why didn't we play Bishop
D2 but trading dark squid Bishops is not
preferable because then the A5 Pawn will
be unattackable and you want to avoid
unattackable weaknesses we have to try
to keep our dark squared Bishop alive in
order to be able later on in the game to
attack the weakness on A5
um and Bishop E6 right is what I was
worried about previously but here Bishop
B6 we could even play Rook D3 straight
away
using some nice little tactics because
then if black plays Bishop C4 we play
Rook C3 and we skewer the bishop to the
C pod so Bishop E6 Rook D3
okay black and play Bishop B4 but then
the bishop is out of the game and we can
try to keep the bishop out of the game
if the bishop goes back let's say to E5
or F6
and already we can take on E6 and try to
go Bishop D2 and try to tie down the
Rook to A8 and when we tie down a piece
we can then start playing on the other
side of the board with the understanding
that our opponent doesn't have
sufficient resources to address
whatever's happening on the other side
because we're tying him down to a
long-term weakness on the queen side
okay so already I like the I like the
way this game is going I like the
progress that we're making here and
we're posing some difficult decisions to
Black okay Rook D3 Bishop B6
okay now Rook D3
and this is even trickier right because
we're we're giving him a chance to make
a tactical error Bishop takes C4 we play
Rook takes C3 and we win the C6 pawn and
remember the key rule when we've got
opposite called Bishops
the opposite Court Bishop positions are
not drawn with Rooks on the board
uh so you should you should not be
worried about that at all all right
let's think so we have to take
okay so King B2 almost Min tempo for
Tempo black survives this
C4 is interesting but I don't like it
C3 Bishop A3 King C2 D5 wow honestly I
overlooked that sequence
still think white is better though
okay think think Bishop D4 as possible
but then black castles again
don't like it hmm
I thinking B2 we have to play this very
slowly ah I have an idea
okay
I think we should begin
yes I think we should go King B2 for
starters
I don't like F4 in this I mean this gets
very subtle this this is going to get
very positional and when I say that you
know what do I mean by that I mean it's
a lot of what what I'm about to do is
based on
like understanding peace placement and
it's not based on variation so when you
ask a question in the post game analysis
too don't expect me to say oh the reason
I didn't do this is because of x y and z
a lot of this has to do with my feeling
of where the pieces belong and where we
can maximize our advantage so D5 F3 this
is actually the reason why I did not
want to push up for I wanted to reserve
the possibility of defending the pawn
with F3 now I'm seeing two things this
bishop on B4 is pissing me off but
playing the move C3 is a very bad idea
because not only do we soften up our B3
Pawn but we we will no longer be able to
play Bishop to D2 and attack the A5 Pawn
so my idea is to switch from attacking
the A5 Pawn to piling up on the second
weakness that black has which is the C6
Pawn I'm liking the look of Bishop to D2
eventually in order to try to trade off
the bishop so that we can eventually put
a rook on C3 and attack black down the C
file but to do all of that we need to
bring all our pieces into the game so
let's start with Rook hdd1 which is sort
of like a neutral move I want to see
what black ends up doing here
um we're not attacking the D5 phone
that's not the point of this move we're
just sort of generally bringing the Rook
into the game okay and I'm trying to
prevent black from expanding on the
queen side with C5 or E5 by preemptively
piling up on the d-pawn so we're trying
to immobilize Flex Pawn structure
so I believe that white is better here
but not much I think it's a slight Edge
for us and if black plays well he should
draw this but it's a difficult position
for black to play because he's got a lot
of weaknesses he's got these weaknesses
on the queen side we've got a super
compact Pawn structure with no
weaknesses and we've got a lot of ways
that we can try to improve our position
here
H6
now here
the idea that I was mentioning earlier
is Bishop D2
how does Bishop D2 work well when we
play Bishop D2 and black trades on D2 We
then reserve the possibility of playing
Rook C3 and sticking The Rook on this
Prime real estate on C5
so I really think Bishop D2 is a Worthy
worthy try
but the drawback of Bishop D2 is that
black can take and stick The Rook on the
second rank Rook F2 and we have to
address that concretely but I think that
concretely works out for us let's
quickly go Bishop D2 and see
let's let's pose this problem to Black
and the way we're trying to play is also
to pose a lot of decisions and dilemmas
for black which given the clock
situation is a very unpleasant way of
playing
okay so we're playing Bishop D2 okay he
doesn't react
doesn't react but can't we now take yeah
I think we should take now
yeah we should definitely take okay and
now now we our plan has succeeded
and we can try to attack this C6 Pawn
with the move Rook C3 and try to get the
Rook to C5 and then maybe even try to
get the other Rook to C3 and then we
really start massaging Black's
weaknesses you know really gets
unpleasant there now of course why am I
not worried you might wonder about D
take C4 because I'm intuitively just
understanding that black has three pawns
we can pick off all of them and black
will only at most be able to take the E4
punt so I'm not even really calculating
D takes E4 I am assuming that Rook B6
here is absolutely forced then let's go
Rook C5 because that's a pretty
automatic move it's not going to hurt us
to attack another weakness on A5 still I
think the position is not much better
for us I think we're still within the
realm of slightly better but the
situation is starting to shift and black
is losing the threat of the game you can
feel it he cooperated he basically
cooperated with us
and by cooperating with us he's given us
everything that we want and now I think
Rook A6 is another mistake I think it
was better to play Rook A8 now I'm
asking myself the question first of all
what happens if we play Rook D3 and I'm
rejecting this move because black is in
time to get his King over to D7 and then
our Rooks are just sort of staring at
the pawn we need to create more
weaknesses we need to apply the
principle not necessarily of two
weaknesses but the principle of more
weaknesses and we need to ask ourselves
okay can we open up another theater of
the game
and the answer is yes let's start with E
takes D5 let's start with E takes D5 if
CD then we win the pawn and we're
grooving and now we can break apart the
pawn chain with C4
and the point of C4 is first of all to
remove this Pawn on D5 which is
restricting our rook and second of all
to open up more prospects for our Rooks
so C4 is kind of a no-brainer move it
should be logical it should be a logical
move to you it should strike you as
logical because when black takes our
Rook on D1 has a lot better prospects
and we're threatening Rook D7 there at
this point I think white is much much
better maybe even technically winning
already maybe even technically winning
but to win this is actually very
difficult because it's a rook end game
and Rook end games one mistake and you
accidentally let your opponent get
active and you know I don't need to
lecture you on this this is a known fact
yeah it's coming together nicely here
and our opponent I think is sensing that
that the game is slipping away from so
he's giving up a pawn well I will oblige
I will take it yeah and King D6 I saw
this line so here we have a choice of
two two options the first is maybe a
move that he missed which is Rook takes
C6 check and we reach a technical
position as a result where we're up a
pawn we have a three on Two And we
should probably be able to convert that
into a win but we should briefly check
if there's anything better and the only
other move is Rook D to C1 C takes D5
Rook takes C7 that hits the G7 pun
that's a more tactical way of playing
that's a more ambitious way of playing I
think I'm trying to win with both Rooks
on the board it's kind of hard to say
which is the better option here let me
think
I think both options are very appealing
obviously
but more calculation is required in the
in the latter option
okay let's go with the uh let's go with
the calmer option rook c60c and now our
general plan is to do two things first
of all we need to monitor the activity
of our pieces and probably we should
start with King C3 but maybe even not
maybe we should start with the move
rookie one you know why because if we
play King C3 then black will play this
annoying little move rookie 8 and black
will constantly be threatening to to
infiltrate with with his Rook to E2 now
if we start with the move Rook to E1
black can of course play Rook to d8 and
probably will but then we can bring our
King up to C3 and we've got the perfect
setup because we are essentially
very safely and securely controlling all
of the infiltration squares and then we
can work on stage two or phase two of
our plan and phase two of our plan is to
start very carefully and judiciously
advancing our King side pawns with two
AIMS in mind of course to create a pass
Pawn eventually but also to restrict the
activity of blackstroke and to soften up
black spawns okay so I think we should
go rookie four for starters and and
centralize our Rook let's centralize our
Rook also we're potentially preparing B4
and why is B4 good because B4 creates an
outside passer
okay so we can play King C3 here first
but then baby block will play C5 so we
have an important very important moment
if we want to play before we should do
it now if we don't then it's fine to go
King C3 and I think we don't I think
we're okay going King C3 here I don't
mind him going C5
yeah let's go King C3
because if black plays C5 I feel like
the pawn on A5 will be a long-term
weakness and rather than trading it we
can actually try to win it with our Rook
we can try to win it by going around
with our Rook
and we can also go into B5 with our King
so C5 weakens the queen side quite a bit
and I'm just it's just not a scary move
if he attacks the h-bond we can defend
it very easily we can play H4 that's
partially why we put the Rook on e4 we
can even play H3 it doesn't matter Rook
G5 we can play G4 so this frontal attack
on our pawns is never going to lead to
success okay now again we can play B4
and this time it's a lot more appealing
with our King a little bit more active
but I don't see a reason why we cannot
start by locking up Black's pawns here
with H4 maybe I allowed G5 maybe that
was a bad idea I don't know but then
maybe B4 already
yeah G5 probably a mistake by me to
allow G5
probably a mistake but maybe not maybe
just before and we win yeah I think just
before
let's go B4 let's go let's create the
passer
why am I creating a passer now well my
logic is this after the trade we're
gonna take with our King to keep our
King as active as possible
and we will already be very close to
being able to play A5 and starting to
promote our a pawn but I'm also looking
over at the Kingston and I'm saying okay
if black plays G takes H4 we play Rook
takes H4 and then we will be very very
close to creating another pass spawn on
the king side and if we get two past
spawns on both sides of the board with a
minute on the clock I mean if black
defends this Kudos okay here we go we
already have a passer and here's the
second one we have two passers on both
sides of the board this has to be
winning this has to be winning but how
do we actually convert this
check
here what if we push
should we push should we push now or
should we push later we can also push F4
by the way and then try to walk our King
up to C4 and D4 but I don't like that
idea not easy not easy at all to convert
this A5 is probably a mistake
okay
go like this
like looking C4
G5 this guy is very good
yeah I might be losing the thread a
little bit here but I still think we're
winning
before maybe
yeah let's go G4
and now Rook G4 and I should be winning
here this should be winning this should
be winning but it's going to be hard to
convert it should be winning I think
practically speaking because we have two
passwords and we'll lock is only one
but he's playing this I have to commend
our opponent it's playing this
incredibly well
but still I mean King D3
okay check probably
or maybe aha maybe we can play like this
and cut off the king essentially trying
to cut off the king here cut off the
king man I mean if he defends this I'll
be very impressed
nicely done yeah for rookie one I mean
this is all correct I think of our
opponent let's try rookie four I'm gonna
torture black here now
I feel like this is a draw
and very confidently too like I feel
like I got I'm getting outplayed out out
understanding here
but still very difficult because we're
gonna start playing F4 we're gonna start
playing F4
okay King B6 let's go F4 man it's still
very hard to hold this very hard to hold
and I have some really tricky ideas like
if he plays C5 I think he loses I think
if you play C5 he loses most people
would play C5 here I mean this is like
an automatic move yeah check I think we
win now check
and then Rook back to E5
yeah I think we win now
no no I think he played incredibly well
but I I think this is just a good
endgame player
um
is it winning takes
okay we haven't cut off this should be a
win
we have him cut off this should be
winning
okay I have five
yeah this should be winning
it's a Lucina position
it's basically a Lucina position yeah
this is Classic this is a Lucina
position
there is a game in the in the Women's
World Cup where this exact end game was
featured today this is really
interesting and this is okay it's not
even a Lucina black is so freaking cut
off that black is not even close to
exiting this pawn and we basically just
push the pawn
we basically just pushed the pawn check
black starts checking us from behind it
doesn't matter we go the basic idea here
is you go to f8
you go to f8 you push F7
and then you get a Lucina
but you don't even need those you know
let me think what is the easiest way to
win this let me think for a second the
easiest way to win this is not even to
use the Lucina it's to go rookie eight
it's to go rookie eight and then King E7
because we can basically make our way
out of the checks through C5 yeah you
don't even need the Lucina method here
you just you just draw you just win
easily
yeah King E7 and that's it you can go
either way you can go like this you can
go like this but the basic thing to
understand is the pawn defends the rook
and all you need to do is zigzag your
way out of the checks the only thing to
avoid here is of course to step onto F4
with your king you can go to E5 although
I wouldn't do this but you can go to E5
just don't go to F4 because then black
plays Rook F1 check and wins the pawn so
like you can the best thing to do is to
go down the C file Etc
and this is resignable I think I
misplayed the end game initially and
then I found this really cool idea
rookie 6 rookie five there's a lot to
talk about in this game a lot to talk
about so let's delve in really a lot to
talk about
okay
GG our opponent played incredibly well
I think I played very well too I think
this is a very high level game
now generally when you play positional
games like this the accuracy is going to
be on the lower side because the moves
are very open-ended it's 87.8 so pretty
good
okay it was it was a it was a good game
I think there were a lot of inaccuracies
by both of us but overall I'm very happy
with that game okay because this was a
10 plus 5 game I apologize if I didn't
explain stuff thoroughly during the game
but I will do that now you pull up chess
base here and I'm gonna pull up the chat
on my phone yeah so many cool ideas in
this game that will be easier to
understand if you're experienced in the
end game like if you have no experience
in these types of end games you're like
how did you come up with this how did
you come up with this how did you know
about that all of it is understandable
you just need experience
okay so we played the Belgrade Gambit
anyway I don't remember what we faced
the first game I think it might have
been Bishop C5 uh but you know I'll have
the link in the chat uh in the
description
Knight before is yeah this is one of the
top engine recommendations oh before we
uh go into this of course our opponent
started with Knight C6 and we played
Knight F3 so here are the only
independent move is D5 and hopefully I
explained independent value well so the
majority of people play E5 here the only
serious independent move is D5 against
D5 I think the way that I like to play
is takes takes Knight C3 this isn't an
inferior scandi because black has this
very awkward move and against Queen A5
you immediately punish black by playing
Bishop B5 Bishop D7 and D4 this is a
very bad position for black
there are some Theory there is some
Theory here like black and Castle
quickly and this can be a little bit
scary but in this version it's a very
bad line A6 I think you play Bishop C6
Bishop c695 I analyzed this recently
and the basic idea is you're hitting C6
and F7 black has to go like this and you
initiate the queen side attack with B4
B4 is a very thematic move
and queen F3 and you're winning because
Rook B1 is threatened and you're
attacking B7
yeah this our D6 is also an independent
move no D6 transposes to the perk I
usually
usually when black plays D6 you
transpose into a line of the perk or
blackways Knight C6 this is what I mean
now when I used to play this with black
I would in fact start with Knight C6
yeah so there is this line of the perk
or blackface D6 true and this is a big
line so I don't have time to talk about
this right now but the basic idea is you
go D4
uh you go Knight F3 sorry or sorry
Knight F3 D6 D4
and typically if black plays it the way
Magnus likes to play it it's Knight F6
Knight C3 G6 and here I think the line
the best line is to play Bishop E3
Bishop G7 and queen D2 very traditional
style
and if black castles then you play D5
granddelius played this against me
Knight B8 and Bishop H6 this position is
theoretical and it's better for white
this is what I really like against the
system and I it's very unpleasant
typically black chips away at the center
with C6 and White Castles Queen side you
can check this out with the engine on
your own
this is just a Direction I Would point
you in also remember that in such
positions you're never afraid of Knight
G4 this is a very common misconception
Knight G4 is not scary because you can
play either Bishop F4
or Bishop G5 actually
um Bishop G5
typically blackplay is H6 and you can
play a bunch of different moves but you
can just play Bishop H4 and like this is
not scary and black plays G5 and black
runs out of tempo moves and then later
on you can play them with H4 and really
smash at uh Black's very weak pawns on
G5 so this is not scary
there are positions where an iq4 is
scary but this is not one of them
generally positions where the pawn is
already on H6 you should take Knight G4
more seriously that makes sense
okay so this is a brief overview of the
alternative options in this game we
transpose to evolving Gambit and
blackway's night before okay fantastic
so again say before
Knight F6 is the only serious move
and after Queen F6
uh the main line the old main line is
this move Bishop C4 and I don't know
what the current theoretical standing of
this move is I checked this with the
engine
and didn't love it because blackway's
Bishop C5 and there are some very
exciting lines here there's there are
some very exciting lines like you castle
if black castles this is a very bad move
who can tell me why it is a bad idea for
black to Castle this is a subtle point
but it's a very instructive Point why
should black have to start with D6
hear what is already better
it's because of E5 and it makes it very
hard for black to develop their Queen
side so for instance look at this
position uh this has happened in several
games generally black blades like this
you play this very powerful move A3
and the point is if Knight takes C2 then
there's Bishop D3 forking the queen and
the Knight so you force the Knight back
to C6
and uh here you play rookie one and you
just get a big initiative here because
when black plays D6 you can play Bishop
D3 and you start pushing black around
now let's see who can find the best move
here for white there is a very important
move here for white without which this
whole sequence wouldn't work because if
you just take well black takes to the
bishop black is up a pawn and we have
nothing to show for it but we strike at
the other side of B4 and you will see
this move commonly in the Belgrade you
force the bishop back of course now you
take and Black's Pawn structure is
completely ruined and you can develop
the bishop or develop the bishop and
attack D6 white has an initiative in a
great position for instance let's say
black plays D5 now we strike with B5
and uh already black is in huge trouble
just look at this bishop D6 rookie five
I mean Knight G5 like this is why the
Belgrade can be really fun to play
because the pieces have a lot of active
potential devil up the bishop yeah
so
for this reason black has to ask has to
know to play D6 and you can still play
E5 this is the main line
this is the main line Bishop G5
Pawn takes Bishop G5 Queen F5 rookie one
attacking the E5 Pawn black has to know
to play the cold-blooded Bishop D6
C3 and here black has to know a very
nice trick if black plays DC pause the
video and figure out what happens what
happens here
what happens what does white do does
white just play BC no white plays rookie
five out of nowhere anytime you have
this construction you should be aware
that this is a mating idea
if black plays Knight C6 then CD and
white is grooving this is amazing for
White You're Gonna Go Bishop D3 and
queen G4 you have a rookie four and
white is a big initiative unfortunately
black is a very devilish idea black and
castle and you should understand very
quickly what the point is cbe4 and black
recovers the piece with a small
Advantage because if the Knight moves
then you take the bishop now white can
go Knight C4 Queen G5 Rook E4 and it's
equal or actually the engine gives
Knight D2 here I put Knight D2 here and
94. this is the way to equalize Queen E5
takes takes rookie 4 and black has white
has some compensation for the pawn
because the queen can come out to F3
this should be equal so this is a very
good alternative line you can play this
line as well because black has to know a
lot after Bishop C4
um now Bishop C5 is not the only option
here and there's a lot of theory in this
very sharp line D5 e d Bishop G4 this is
another very sharp line you can do some
analysis on your own I know there's a
chessable course on the Belgrade I don't
know what the author recommends it might
be Bishop C4 but I decided to play this
in a somewhat more technical way because
this is a less known concept A3 Knight
C6 Bishop D3
so here there are two basic ways that
black can develop their pieces of course
black can play Bishop C5 and as I've
already indicated you almost always meet
Bishop C5 with B4 Bishop drops back to
B6 you Castle
and uh typically black plays D6 and now
you play B5 you force this Knight to
commit to a square
if Knight A5 then you should already
know what the trick is you play E5 and
Bishop G5 with a huge initiative then
Knight 65. okay
black of course should play 95. now you
take it very counter-intuitive unless
you understand the idea and the idea is
to immediately begin the kingside
initiative with this very powerful move
F4 and white gets excellent compensation
for the pawn so if black doesn't react
then you push F5 and suddenly the bishop
is out of the game let's say black
pretends that nothing is the matter
Queen H5
now you're threatening Bishop G5 and F6
and if black plays H6 then Rook F3 and
white is mating this is just completely
winning right off the bat
so it's really nice this idea of f4 F5
and it's not easy to meet because if
black plays e takes F4 you play Bishop
takes F4 okay probably black has to move
the queen away and now uh you can play
A4
just solidifying the situation on the
queen side castles E5 and I mean just
look at this queen H5 is coming and it's
a white is already better
so I really really like this line I
think this B4 B5 B4 castles B5 idea is
super cool
um if black refrains from D6 and castles
himself then B5 is even better because
here in this version white plays F4
and very instructive moment in this
position okay let's say queen E7 what do
you think white should do what would you
play here intuitively what do you think
white should do this is a bit of a trick
question
but what do you think white should do
yeah so there is E5 and there's F5 the
correct move is actually I think
counterintuitive it's F5
when I look at this position as a
intermediate player I'm thinking and I'm
not saying this by any means to
condescend like this is a reasonable way
of thinking about it I want to open up
my Bishop let's go E5 the problem with
the movie five is that black always has
this D6 move and when the Center opens
up it's very hard to devote your
attention to the king side so you can
make this one move threat Queen H5 oh my
gosh apparently according to the engine
white has a crazy idea here but this is
just a one move threat apparently in
this position so I stand corrected I
stand corrected black has to go D5 if
black plays D6 there is a sexy idea F5
anyway
and if black plays de you should
understand where this is going you just
throw this Pawn into F6
black Takes It and Bang
and bang
and bang with a rook lift and a mate
just again look how quickly these
attacks just result in Victory if black
plays Queen takes E5
then you play this slower move Queen G4
and the point is after black develops
you just go Bishop F4 black plays Queen
back to F6 you play Bishop G5 rookie one
Bishop F6 Queen G5 and mate on G7 really
really sick lines and notice this queen
G4 Moves Like These you should not be
afraid to play why do how do you know
that you can play a slower move because
Black is Black is not threatening
anything everything is protected so you
have the ability to accumulate your
initiative with moves like Queen G4 of
course you could play F6 here but this
this this is not quite as powerful
because of G6
okay and here F6 makes contact with the
queen so black has to react to this move
okay
so this is Bishop C5 our opponent played
D6 now we go Bishop B5 yeah Bishop G4 is
good uh Bishop D7 is also possible some
people play like this and here we go
Bishop G5 Queen G6 Bishop takes C7 I
really like this position and I've
talked about this I remember we had this
position in the previous speed run in
the analysis section
here you can play Bishop C6 Bishop C6
and now Knight H4 I showed this move in
the previous speed run this Knight H4
Knight F5 idea is really powerful
obviously Queen E4 there's rookie one
Queen F6 you go 95 and you can go for
instance um Queen D3 rookie one and
eventually you recover the pawn with a
small advantage
so
in any case this is um Bishop D7 our
opponent to his great credit new to play
Bishop G4 and now play Queen takes C4
inaccuracy correct would be Bishop E7
this is one of the best lines against
the Danish
and black is
not like much better but it's like a
tiny tiny Edge for it so here's how the
line goes essentially white has no
better move than just to take the queen
and here compared to the uh end game
that we had obviously it's an it's an
improved version for black white is
supposed to go C3
and black goes queenside white goes
Bishop E3 and black very quickly deploys
all of his pieces into the center
forcing us to play this relatively
passive move Bishop D3 and now for
instance D5 he takes D5 this is equal
like white has made a couple of careful
moves and here white equalizes with
Castle's Queen side but yeah I mean this
this line is is pretty much a killer
Bishop E7
the point is if if White Castles then
black and play Bishop takes F3 and here
you have to trade queens and play GF and
this is not a desirable structure of
course if black plays Bishop F3 here
then we are able to also ruin black
structure and that changes the picture
that that means it's a different story
so remember if you want to play this
with black or Bishop E7 and this
neutralizes the line E5 is another
attempt to open up a discovered attack
on the bishop but simply Queen E6
protects the bishop and the pawn on E5
is a Sitting Duck because Bishop takes
F3 is also threatened
so anyways we could spend like forever
on this end game but I don't want to
spend too long on any individual
decision I want to talk about it in more
broad Strokes
so first of all
um I explained during the game my
decision to play Knight takes c66 I I
don't think Bishop C6 makes any sense
because the Knight is not a very good
piece here because it's going to be
chased away with the move C5 so this to
me is a pretty much a no-brainer right
Knight takes C6 I copy this into chat
space so I can so I can look at some
some gains of the engine
so BC first point that I want to
reiterate is that the price of a move
and you'll hear this phrase sometimes
the price of a move is not very high
so you might look at this in the engine
and see okay the engine gives
approximately equivalent it evals to
Bishop A6 Bishop D3 and Bishop C2 that's
because truly the moves there is not
such a big difference between those
moves some of you were suggesting Bishop
Basics it's an interesting move and I
should have given it more credit
probably because you you literally
blockade the a pawn but to me it seemed
a little bit too awkward just a little
bit
okay so instead we decided to go back to
D3 sort of a more defensive move Bishop
E7 Bishop E3 Bishop F6 castles I think
this stretch makes perfect sense and B3
is the top engine move actually
so here I was able to override my
intuition and make I think a much more
challenging move why again did I not
play C3 because after C3 C5 for instance
B2 is a long-term Target that black can
ultimately attack by doubling Rooks on
the B file so I just didn't see a
downside to the move B3 here black can
of course also plays C5 and what would
we have done if black had played C5 well
here I saw a very aggressive idea that
involves going F4
and what do we do if black castles who
can tell me a very interesting and
interesting move that creates some
tension
an interesting move that creates
intention and just give me a moment not
F5 I don't like F5
I don't like F5 I don't like G4 because
you've already traded Queens don't give
up your Pawn like that E5 yeah the movie
five is very challenging for black
because if black takes
then it's easy to see well you can just
play Bishop C5 and A7 hangs this is out
of the question so black has to go like
this and now what's a good move just to
keep the tension just keep the tension
Rook HD1 and black has a pretty
unenviable situation black is cramped we
have good pieces and we keep going it's
again it's not Earth it's nothing Earth
shattering I think it is though a
slightly better position let's check
with the engine gives the engine gives
I'm going to turn stockfish on and see
what what it gives in this position
because I'm pretty sure F4 is a very
good move whoa okay 24.
yeah the engine gives um
C5 F4 is the top move castles
top move according to the engine oh very
interesting look at this Pawn on C7
believe it or not that pawn can be
attacked white is better here that pawn
can be attacked with this move Bishop D2
this also prevents A5 you're going to A5
with the bishop so let's say blackplay
is a neutral move Bishop A5 now you
might say how hard is this Pawn to
defend very hard if C6 Bishop C7 wins if
Rook C8 Bishop A6
so black is the resort to this nasty
little move and now as I said we
immediately switch our attention to the
center Rook HD1 and Black's position is
very uncomfortable very uncomfortable
it's hard to make a move here for black
black is very tied down so for example
let's say black plays Bishop C6 right
and now E5 now we strike at the center
now obviously you should see that Bishop
G2 Ed is winning for white because of
the back rank issues so black has to
basically support The Rook on E8 with
King f8 and now simply Bishop F1 look at
the engine plays it every move attacks
something what you are trying to achieve
is to lure black into this structure now
black is saddled with you know these
massive weaknesses on the queen side you
might say well what about the epon yeah
you have to give something up you can't
make an omelette without breaking some
eggs but it's about plus minus black has
an empty check on G5 that doesn't do
anything you just tuck your king away on
B2 then you can also go Bishop C4 Bishop
D5 and trade off black strong piece
really instructive to see how the engine
handles these positions so our opponent
played A5 A4 is a good move white is
better Bishop C3 top engine move by the
way Bishop C4
the idea is to play Rook D3 Black Goes
Bishop E6 and this I think may be an
inaccuracy but we're not going to focus
on it I think Bishop E6 is very
reasonable
so Brook D3 Bishop B4 Bishop takes C6 F
takes C6 and here I made a mistake here
I made a mistake we are almost winning
with the move C3
now who can tell me Let me refresh
because I got disconnected who can tell
me why did I not play C3 I saw this move
and at first blush it may seem that C3
traps the bishop or forces black to play
Bishop C5 and then black gets triple
pawns but what does black actually do
here it's just that I underestimated to
say oh my God this is beautiful
beautiful idea that I missed so
instructive the check
but what does black do here that I was
afraid of because we are threatening to
play Rook A1 and force Bishop C5 which
would triple black spawns what is the
point of Black's play here oh this is
incredible
C5
no come on what do you mean C5 D5 black
has to play D5 no you have to pay
attention to what's going on if black
castles we force this structure I mean
look at this this is a disaster black is
losing here no black has to open up a
diagonal for his Bishop with D5 okay
but now there is an incredible idea
before
a takes B4 I saw this
what did I think I thought that we have
to play like this and I saw the black
and gold B3 check and again the bishop
evacuates
But Here There is a crazy computer idea
that wins the game does anybody see it
let's see who can find it
this is so instructive there's actually
two good moves here but one idea wins
the game it's actually not King B3 King
B3 is winning
but even better is CB
you're like doesn't that defeat the
whole purpose of what we just did now
look at Black's broken look at Black's
Bishop suddenly you go rugby one and it
all seems very simple King D7 Rook db3
C5 bang Bishop C5 that's it you win The
Rook in the corner you literally just go
CB and you exploit this Rook on B8 and
the fact that Black's Rooks are
uncoordinated and then either Rook B3 or
Rook B1 winning the game
and I missed this I missed I missed the
whole concept of either going King B3 or
going CB I did not take this idea
seriously enough because I wasn't really
looking for tactics I was already in my
mind psychologically intent on playing
positionally and this was a very
instructive mistake so I went King B2 to
prepare C3 but this gave black the time
that he needed to open up the pathway
back for the bishop and now the game
continues not easy to find at all not
easy to find what does King B3 do as
sorrow so again King B3 is not the best
move King B3 very simple you're
preventing B3 black is threatening to
play B3 here and get the bishop out of
there you are physically preventing it
what is White's next move gonna be here
who can tell me let's say black plays
you know something like King D7 what is
uh White's next move likely to be yeah
it's gonna be Bishop C5 and CB the
reason this is not so simple is because
black can play this move and if you play
CB Suddenly It's A Swindle takes takes
and rook hb8 and then C5 if necessary
so okay this is complicated but the
engine gives this move you basically
leave the black Bishop in the dust so
you're not playing to trap the bishop
you are playing to leave the bishop
imprisoned so that black is effectively
playing a piece down on the other side
of the board
super super instructive I missed it I
went pb2 after D5 F3 castles okay white
is only slightly better Rook HD1 or
clearly better but not winning H6 and
Bishop D2 the next stage a very strong
move I think leaving or forcing the
trade of Bishops and making it easier
for us to attack Black's weaknesses on
the queen side okay King F7 trade now of
course black could play 86 before here
maybe this was more resilient but this
gives us this incredible long-term trump
card in the form of a protected passer
on on A4 what we do what would we do
here
probably we would play the move uh Rook
C1 and then quickly C3 to open up the C
file and Target Black's weak pawns on
the C file okay so Rook before is what
most people would play Rook C3 Rook B6
Rook C5
Rook A6 and edc4 bang opening up another
front and at this point Black's position
is lost I think King E6
CD King D6
how would you go about finding moves
like C3 in a classical game well you
just have to consider it because the
bishop is almost trapped I should have
spent longer considering this move
because it I mean if you see before then
you should look at it because if this
works then it wins the bishop so lines
that have such a high benefit if they
work should be you should devote more
time to them you should be more stubborn
uh but no there's no way to guarantee
that you find something like this it
just exists there's no formula otherwise
everybody would find it
okay Rook HD1 Bishop D2 trade attack the
the pawn attack the pawn and Force black
to be even more passive and now edc4 why
did we need to play e takes d45 because
if we had gone C4 immediately we give
black the bailout option of playing D
take C4 and we certainly do not want to
give black the free f file also notice
that the fifth rank is not as accessible
to the black Rogue so it's very
important to first take on D5 and then
play C4 and obviously I think black
probably should have gone DC but this
position is miserable absolutely
miserable
um Rook takes C4
and we are threatening Rook D7
so the engine line is rookie 8 Rook D7
rookie seven trade and we get a very
similar position to what we got in the
game white should be technically winning
yeah back in Speed Run mode so CD King
D6 and I think this was a critical
moment where
yeah I made a mistake here very
interesting I made a mistake Rook takes
C6 gives away a good part of the okay
it's still winning but it's much much
harder to convert
um Rook dc1 was correct it's plus three
the reason I didn't like this is because
it gives black the passer but it turns
out the black just cannot survive so for
example Black Goes G5 and now you swing
Rook H7
King E5
check
if King F4
then you go Rook D7 and look at just how
you you basically
attack Black's weaknesses and black is
too overextended to defend who can find
the beautiful win after Rook F5 there is
a lovely win here for white pause the
video and see if you can find it again
always looking for tactics even when you
are in quote unquote convert mode
foreign
King G4
if King E4 then rookie 7 rookie five
rookie one is a classic attacking The
Rook from both sides
but if King G4 you have to see this move
H3 and you you disattach the king from
the rook and win
so this wins for white because white
one's the Deep one if the King goes the
other way right if the King goes to D4
then you go from behind same technique
you go one Rook from behind
then the other Rook from in front
and King C5 you can try to dislodge The
Rook with G4
rookie five
and Rook B7
and then you go Rook B5
and black is completely tied down black
has basically no moves it's zuzwang
after King C6 Rook B5 black is basically
in zug's one and then you can go like
let's say King T6 you can go Rook D3
black has to shuffle and then you walk
your king up King C3 King D6 and King D4
look at how methodically the engine
converts this position
King E6 and we go back to B8 and win the
game because this is Unstoppable or this
is Unstoppable
so just instructive to see how you make
one improving move after the other but I
underestimated this I underestimated how
bad Black's King was and how weak these
two pawns are on uh on H6 and on on D5
so I didn't devote sufficient attention
to this idea
instead we decided to trade like this
and here I think that the conversion is
much harder I have to commend our
opponent on playing Super well so work
on fiber K4 first thing we do is we
centralize The Rook we put it on an
optimal Square then we bring our King up
King C3 H5
I actually think that this this
no-brainer move H4 was a mistake yeah H4
was a mistake very instructive mistake
why did not we try to go rookie seven
the reason I didn't go rookie seven here
is because it doesn't do anything you
should not automatically put the Rook on
the seventh rank it's not always that
good here black has the move Rook G5 but
it was correct Rook G5 G4 we should have
gone like this you're right we should
have gone rookie seven here I was
somehow skeptical of this move H5
but does anybody see what white can do
here to basically win the game on the
spot you can freeze black with this very
important technique what is it H4 yeah
H4 Rook g65 just look at this very
carefully The Rook cannot move what is
White's plan well you're just gonna go
F4 and F5 and where do we go if Black
Goes King D6 very instructive point you
go Rook F7 you need to prevent the black
king from being able to assist the rook
and you win the game obviously
so somehow I was afraid of ghosts what
happens if black plays G5 then rookie 6
Rook H6 stupid I completely forgot about
this move I and I just didn't appreciate
it and the but the real mistake is H4
because it allows G5
and what you might say why is this a
mistake like why does this favor Black
because if you look at this position
suddenly the G2 Pawn is a weakness and
this is premature you don't want to put
your cards on the table too soon on the
king side why not because you want to
basically leave black with potential
targets until you are ready to make a a
pass spawn and we're not ready yet to
make a past spawn so the correct move
would have been to give this check first
and after King E6 you just continue to
make improving moves with King C4 and
black is busted black is no moves here
because rookie five rookie 4 is a
winning Pawn end game probably our
opponent would continue to push response
and now we play H4 what is the
difference well the difference is
immense
here
let's compare this position
to this position
here after hgfg black and play C5 and
it's absolutely not clear how to make
progress
meanwhile here we play F4 we can play
the move F4
using the fact that we're aiming at the
H5 Pawn and look at this position
carefully white is winning because black
cannot defend A5
Rook F2
you can even go King B5 this is kind of
advanced but white is winning here
and now King C6
really pretty Rook F3
Rook takes A5 Rook takes B3
and Rook C5 it's not necessarily
Elementary to you the black is winning
but white is winning but white is
because the king is too far away so
already the technique is much harder
rookie 4 was a big mistake I should have
gone with my chance in gun rookie seven
already here you have to be super
precise
now after B4 it should be a draw a
before King before
GH4 King C6 good move King C4
yeah now it's a draw G4 takes takes
Rook C5 King D3 let me tell you where
black went wrong
I'm gonna tell you where black went
wrong
wow this is a decisive mistake because
of f4 apparently but that's hard to see
apparently the drawing move is King B6
F4 C5 and you'll be able to tell how
hard this is just by the engine line
Rook E4
and now you go back to C6
if white continues to push you go King
D7 absolutely not obvious like why is
this a draw C4 check oh my God this is
what I'm talking about
you sacked the pawn and win it back on
the other side and it's because of this
that this is a draw otherwise it's lost
so like okay to find this King B65 how
do you know when to do that our opponent
played a completely natural move rookie
five here I made another mistake here I
made another mistake and the winning
move was F4 I didn't play it because of
rookie because of rookie one but
apparently this is winning because I
have him cut off along this file King C5
Rook F4 ah you put the Rook behind the
pawn so white has to go like this or
black has to go like this
and now you go kingy for
King C5 okay question where should
White's Rook go this is an idea that I
completely overlooked what should I do
in this position
and games are insanely hard insanely
hard Rook D3 with one idea to play Rook
D3 to F3
and dislodge The Rook now everybody in
this chat should know that you should
put Rooks in front of past pawns so that
is the goal here and black is not in
time right if black says oh I'm gonna
start pushing my seep on no you're not
you're just not fast enough by like
actually by like 210 because white
promotes with check
uh so F4 I played rookie four and this
gives black a tempo but apparently King
B6 is a decisive mistake after F4 white
is winning
the drawing move here
was Rook H5 I mean how do you know to
play this move you don't
F4 King D5 you need to keep your king in
the vicinity of the center
Rook D4 King E6
and black basically holds on the fifth
rank white has no way to make progress
that's the point
so Rook H5 white has no way to make
progress here the difference the
difference is that if black tries to do
the same thing here he's not fast enough
because you go King E4 and you make it
make it through to F5
whereas if you compare this to the game
continuation
here you're not making the move F5 in
time Black's King is much better
positioned
so that's about it
King B6 F4 and now it's lost now it's
lost because we're gonna start pushing
the F Pawn
C5 and now this very nice technique
rookie 6 rookie five this one you should
remember
this one you should remember because it
it forces black to lose contact between
the king and the pawn
that's why we don't go rookie five
immediately here because here black can
go Rook D1 and defend from behind we
have to check first and then go rookie
five so that we can win the C bun and
this is always losing
here you have trousers you have fast
pawns on either side of the board and
you win the game
and at this point we're completely
winning that's it this end game I'm not
going to delve into because we're at a
high level in the speed run and I always
tailor my comments to the level we're at
this is completely winning and you
should be comfortable converting it the
basic idea is you advance your king and
then Advance your Pawn which is exactly
what we did you're just Advanced your
king and Advance your pawn and then you
hide the king behind the pawn this is
like the one thing you should just
remember then you push it to F7 and we
don't even need the Lucina position
where you basically build a bridge and
walk your king back you just go rookie
eight and King E7 if Black's King were
on C7 here this would not work because
black would start checking you
although even here it works so this is
just even more winning and now we just
zigzag just avoid this as long as you
avoid this you can keep zigzagging
because the pawn defends the rook and
otherwise we promote
and that's it so the actual decisive
mistake for black according to the
engine was this move King B6 because it
moves the king away from the center and
black should chill in the center here to
be able to meet F4 with King D5
okay
so really rich end game with a lot of
positional details but I'm pretty
exhausted so I'm going to call it here
important ideas included first of all B3
and A4 the concept of fixing your
opponent's weakness on a square where
you can attack it then
okay we had this beautiful C3 idea but
transforming the advantage right trading
off the Bishops in order to improve
access to the other weaknesses tying our
opponent down and then opening up a
second front as my coach would call it
opening up a second front you have your
opponent tied down and then you create
more problems sometimes by opening up
the center or opening up files and that
makes it impossible for your opponent to
defend because he's already so tied down
to the existing weaknesses
then of course we had to go Rook dc1
appreciating the power of the Rook
tandem
and then there were a lot of mistakes in
the send game like I didn't go here
I rushed H4 although this is much harder
to understand and then it should have
been a draw
it should have been a draw with this um
yeah with uh with King B6 and C5 but our
opponent made a mistake I made a mistake
so obviously these end games are almost
impossible to play accurately which is
why I'm gonna forgive myself thank you
code so for the two one and I hope you
enjoyed the game that's about it
Belgrade Gambit really holds up at this
level it's very high level but it still
holds up and next time we will try the
move
Bishop C4 sir sorry here we will try
Bishop C4 and then this whole like E5
Bishop G5 line is definitely worth
investigating all right guys I gotta
head out
um I'll see everybody later thank you
very much for watching hope you enjoyed
this video and this will be out on
YouTube thank you for your support thank
you everybody peace
[Music]